no Adam pelic tonight stemming from the head
shot delivered by Brenan Gallagher on Thursday
in Montreal as Mayfield to the front and Star's
got a stick on it well that was a great play by
the golender deflect that pass Corvette was coming
down the wing he had an empty net here's barzel
from behind the N just Cho in towards The Far Side
Mike Riley the player who started the season with
the Florida Panthers is back into the L barzel
for Lee mused on net the rebound cleared Away
by Montour Islanders also playing without Hudson
fashing in tonight's game he was injured after
that awkward collision with the boards after
being stopped on a breakaway early on in that
hockey game on Thursday night as well so that's
where walstrom comes back in for wining the boards
pretty hard there really short Shi for him yeah
he's laboring right now I think you know how it is
right on the top of the foot really hurts blocker
Away by VAR laama buo down along the end HS AO
kept it from getting out in front pass out hi to
berri kulakov across for alliv Anan Larson his
shot blocker Away by varl forsling will shoot this
one into the Zone remember saying a similar thing
last year at the beginning of the year when Boston
was missing Charlie makavo this one covered up by
barl over the old they just want to tread water
until they get makoy back and then they comes out
High backhanded to the front never got through for
Horvat bursting out of the Zone was r H the pass
on it's Montour shot and a save made by varl the
puck hit the netting the hits excuse me the risk
of getting hit Brandon Montour number 62 he's
an defenseman in your program but man can this
guy ever get up ice he does a bit of everything
roams around 73 points last year Matthew kachuck
had just five goals in his first 36 games he's got
10 in the last 12 here he is splitting in and a
save by varl on Evan Rodriguez watch coming right
up the middle on this on this play Rodriguez just
splited the defense going backwards and then was
able to have the presence of mind to turn around
what a terrific pass that was and break through
that's a different breakout isn't it now the
Islanders have to hustle back final 7 Seconds of
the panther power play Reinhardt though ran right
up the back of his own player home stromman passo
coming again Holstrom shoot save rebound save
Again by stolar kind of goofed it up just a little
bit but they're fun to watch well they they read
off each other youor Bourne I mean you guys had a
lot of fun killing penalties I jump out there once
in a while with you on faceoffs and like to sneak
in once in a while but butch to have that becoming
the head coach and I think you know Brian one of
the things that we're kind of all taking away from
it is a legend of the game like Patrick W as PA
Mar dances through and stars had to make the save
angal try to keep the pressure on but it's stolen
away by eag really brief the if bosy had have been
out there he' probably scored right cuz I mean PA
gets a great opportunity but you know what what
a tremendous move by Palms getting through splits
to the fence hangs on to it didn't have much of an
angle really at the end of the day in the and the
golender today they're so big right they take out
so much he's jumping up on the play he's got that
first pass good skater good Poise all those things
you want in a uh obviously a guy that you want on
the backside that going to bring oh here we go Bo
horv save by star here but uh we're we're thinking
about you borney so wishing you well and see this
opportunity is tried to go quickly by hole but
St stolar is having a good game yeah a good
play go low stick go top shelf keep it keep him
guessing a little bit Nelson turns and shoots
and palmary I think got a piece of it it hit the
outside of the post Islanders have barzel Horvat
and Lee with doson and Romanov on the ice but some
of the big cats out there as well could chuck to
the middle for benon and a kicked Away by V Lama
but barley he's had to be good the isers were all
over the Florida path there for about the first
10 minutes but now barov to the Middle with a shot
blocker saved by varlamov AI around for kachuck
no look to the front and Reinhardt has his 20th
power play goal C didn't even look he knew he
was there Puck came around the boards fired it
out there and the Islanders didn't get that back
to the slot area quick enough and barley got a
part of it but just not enough of it but n's done
a real good job I mean keeping it to the to the
outside and Mayfield there's a shot there by barov
but watch this Puck go all the way around now the
guys have got to hustle into the slot area jasted
behind there was doson thought he might be able to
get it didn't block the pass on the slaughter and
that's where you got to be smarter Brendon there
was no reason to hustle towards PUK and no Hudson
fashing tonight no Adam pelic tonight both injured
in Thursday night's game in Montreal Pou in front
they score Simon Holstrom found it and it leaked
all the way through it in game time goal for Simon
Holstrom well walstrom didn't really win the face
off clean but he stayed right with it hom at the
top of your screen's going to come across but look
at the fight no couldn't quite get it right on
the stick of homest he didn't even know it went in
Brendon and then he realized it and so that this
is a good deal but look at Paso stays right with
it Holstrom stays with it oh horback shoots it
ahead Matt barzel and Anders Lee on a run barzel
Cuts back looks for a trailer finds Romano oh
shoot it returned it shot it that off the post
Florida down at the other end Romanov with a
wicked shot off the off the post and they're
looking for Reinhard but the honors are doing a
pretty good job of just taking him away Montour
set it through kachuck again after kachuck rotates
it for barov marov rot they score traffic in front
of varlamov and snuck through off the post and
in the Chuck may have gotten a piece and it's a
2-1 lead for the Panthers both goals on the power
play Chuck right here you can see Scott Mayfield
doing his best to deter this one from getting
in the net I'm just curious if it goes off a
couple it almost it almost went I don't know
if that went through his skate blade look at
Mayfield there oh right five horn K Chuck he's
so good in front of the net that was able to get
just a little bit of a of a of a of a deflection
Nelson the doson Paul Mar's in front Lee battling
to get there too barzel trying to move move off
the wall the exchange with doson back door they
score Paul Mary the finish what a feed from Thon
and with the extra attacker the Islanders have
tied the game and that was all starting with a
what seemed like a very simple play by barzel
just get it in on the backand but the Islanders
go to work but the Islanders took a while to get
out there's just so much good stuff on this play
but watch col P find his spot great plays great
passes well it's worth nothing if you're not in
the right spot wow is that off the back of the
mask of skolars and got lost in this whole deal
is Andrew Lee who's in front of the net and he's
got a hold of eblad in front with a jam play
shut down at the side of the net by varlamov
then Holstrom wipes out but the Panthers were
headed to the bench for a change headman pass
for Nelson Nelson from an angle shoots save stolar
as he tried to go five hole Islanders caught in
a change now Rodriguez emman Larson to the net
scores Oliver emman Larson the overtime winner
for Florida yeah iser's on a tough change there
just weren't able to get out get the change done
in time and Larsson recognized it and he jumped up
what a burst of speed that was from from Larsson
and he made absolutely no mistake Brock Nelson
with the opportunity and then like I said a tough
change as Rodriguez just goes streaking down
that right side and that crossy pass again is
always difficult for the golender to get position
good play by the golender and re on Rodriguez
knows exactly what's going on he's looking looking
looking and that's a good player that's where for
me Riley's got to slide over more he's got to let
the golender play that you can see where vof is
in so deep Brendan cuz he had to wait and wait and
wait you got to move over and take away that pass